hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about cross multiplication this is a
relatively straightforward math skill
that is a great way to simplify an
equation now what do I mean by
simplifying an equation sometimes you
have equations that are in formats like
this one or this one or this one and
they seem quite complex cross
multiplication is a way to simplify
these equations in order to solve for a
specific variable let's take this
generalized example here any divided by
B equals C divided by D the way cross
multiplication works is you multiply
these corners getting a times D and that
is equal to the multiplication product
of these corners B times C now all you
have to do is determine which of these
variables you want to solve for for
example let's say you've been given a B
and C but asked to solve for D well you
simply divide both sides by a in order
to isolate D on one side of the equation
these A's cancel and you get D is equal
to B times C divided by a and then you
can just plug these numbers in to solve
for D and it's much easier than trying
to work out this equation without cross
multiplication let's look at another
example here we filled in numbers for
some of those variables and you're asked
to solve for x again simplify this using
across multiple
patien this will tell you that 4 times 3
is equal to 6 times X this means 12
equals 6x divide both sides by 6 and you
get that X is equal to 2 another place
you might see this getting even more
complicated is something like the
combined gas law the combined gas law is
one that tells us how gases behave in
certain conditions that is if a gas is
at a certain pressure volume and
temperature and then two of those things
change say the pressure changes in the
temperature changes what is the new
volume so if you were given a problem
like that and asked to solve for the new
volume of the gas v2 just use cross
multiplication multiply these corners p1
times v1 times t2 so thats p1 times v1
times t2 equals the other corners p2
times v2 times t1 remember we were asked
to solve for v2 so we're going to divide
both sides by P 2 and T 1
that means that this P 2 and this P 2
will cancel these t ones will cancel and
we get the end product being that p1
times v1 times t2 divided by p2 times t1
equals v2 and remember that all of these
values you would be given so you can
simply plug them in and solve for v2
that's another great example for how
cross multiplication simplifies a rather
difficult problem so that is it for
today on biology professor I hope you
learned a lot and thanks for watching